let's go next to our caller from the
five one nine area code who's calling
today from five one nine and just as
importantly where are you calling from
David yes okay it's Rowley from Owen
Sound Ontario Canada got a question for
you yeah do you think that maybe mr.
Trump is just fed up with the job and is
deliberately trying to sabotage his
reelection I think he wants to go
golfing I think yes you're not he can
raise all the hell he wants yeah not
have to take any responsibility for it
right your views on that listen Harry a
few people have asked me about this
David Knight David I can't hear you my
phone's acting up so I'm just gonna hang
up and watch for your response on the
show sometime okay that sounds fine
listen I don't believe Trump is
consciously trying to sabotage or
sabotage his own election I think
Trump's ego won't let him do it but I do
believe that if Trump loses he will
justify it by saying hey you know what
it was rigged and I have plenty of
things to do I'm still a rich guy I'm
still going to be able to go and you
know do do whatever it is that I want so
I don't think Trump is deliberately
sabotaging himself I think from the
beginning Trump didn't really want to be
President and were the Republican
electorate not so easily bamboozled able
if that's a word Trump never would have
become their nominee and would never be
President to this day but yeah III think
that if Trump is trying to sabotage his
election he's doing it subconsciously
not consciously and then he will after
the fact certainly say I'm better off
doing doing other stuff anyway